past tutorial whenever you can take it
from here
thank you and thanks everyone i hope you
guys had some good uh
enjoyable break
again i'm sorry i'm missing the
opportunity and i hope
they'll
be able to be there later in the
semester
so i want to go back to
again the same rule says
uh
before will apply uh please chime in if
you have questions i'll do my best to
monitor the uh
the chat window but i mean that's a
little hard so
if you can help that would be
appreciated
um okay so we were not defining this
sort of alternate variant on
on smoothness which is the one i want to
use as my example
uh in a second so
i rewrote here the classical version is
the cost
um that the cost of
the sum of overall costs of what people
would get if they change to the some
special strategy
is less than something times the optimum
oh sorry
the alternate version
for utility games defining it
um
more formally would be
i guess the inequality turns around and
maybe the
the social welfare
of the current solution comes in should
be a subtraction social welfare remember
is a mix of the players value
plus the
and
so what seemed to be this sort of better
version
um or somehow cleaner version uh that
vasily and i uh suggested is forget the
social welfare put in something that
explicitly distinguishes the revenue so
the
some of the utilities that people get
somehow compared to
what the optimum is uh minus
the auctioneer's revenue and this just
as before it very simply implies a price
of energy band or maybe even more simply
at a nash equilibrium
um oh that inequality is backwards so so
the utility sub player should be bigger
than this alternate version
and then all i have to do is rearrange
the inequality and notice that the sum
of these utilities plus revenue that's
what social welfare is and
compares to lambda times the optimum
here i guess this lambda is a below 1
multiplier
because it's a greater than equality the
buffer is not bigger than twice the
optimum it's
hopefully bigger than something like
half the optimum so the price of energy
tends to be a number above one which has
the uh one over lambda here but it's the
as simple as it gets in the band
uh what i want to show you is that these
sort of bands
tend to naturally or seem to naturally
apply in auctions
in many auctions uh
all i'm going to do is first price
because this is not uh
tutorial and actions uh but so again
we're thinking of maybe this is a
again a single item auction with a
player
um that
has his value he knows what it is and i
guess what i want to have him think
about what would happen if you bid half
his value in a first price auction
bidding your real value is definitely
dangerous or useless because if you have
to pay it
then you get no value
even if you win the item
well maybe half your value is reasonable
or some other multiplier like that and
if i think of half the value then the
following inequality is really easy to
argue that the utility no matter what
everyone else bids that you get if you
bit half value is greater than half your
value minus the price and i guess that's
simply because either
uh he wins in which case his utility is
half the value because he only pays the
price which was half the value or his
bid which is half the value and the
other half is his value and that we
don't even need the subjection or
he lost in which case the the price is
above his bid and then this side is
negative and he's getting zero in fact i
guess i can add that this is greater not
just this inequality but also than zero
because utilities
in first price action is you always have
non-negative utility thermometer
unless you bid above your value uh it's
guaranteed
and then i can take this inequality and
say that if you satisfy the no regret
property then whatever happened should
be better than having bids have to value
and
i can add this by the using this
inequality for the person with the top
valuation and the zero part for everyone
else and i get that
uh
this is this action is half smooth half
is the parameter here the lambda used
here that is
it's true that the sum of the values is
greater than
the maximum value
half of the maximum value
minus the price
um so i guess that proved that this
gives a
price of energy band of two and i admit
that factor of half that i used here is
i guess is simple
uh but actually you can do a little bit
better by improving this to
e e minus one over e instead so this is
not actually a sharp band but something
like this
is uh giving you a sharp band
um
this this kind of proofs are
super powerful as we sort of did in some
version and maybe even more
powerful in other ways it works on
bayesian bayesian actions that is um
what happened here is that the proposed
bid this
a star was only a function of the
person's value
all i have to do is take expectation
over it
um
same band applies
all i have to do is take expectation of
bands also applies to no regret learning
outcomes for the very simple classical
and now the same analysis we have seen
before
uh adding up the inequalities and
um and i guess the last important point
to make here is that i'm not actually
asking these bidders to beat have they
value or whatever times they value they
can do whatever they want they just
should not regret this if they're doing
even worse than have been consistently
bidding half they value them they must
be doing something wrong and i have a
proposal for them that improves uh
their behavior
and i guess the theorem here is that
this first price auction
is
uh one-half smooth uh
the bid only depends on the player's
value and when that happens
uh then this analysis extends to
vision outcomes that is randomized
outcomes randomized measures
or all kinds of values of no regret
learning outcomes
so that's sort of a nice general
extension theorem
in fact life is even better
in extension theorem land if i think of
a version of this with multi
unit demands so that is these are
players who would like to buy one of
these houses and they have values i
guess
the optimal social welfare here
so everyone just wants one house
optimal social welfare would be a
maximum matching problem i should assign
everyone to some house so that the sum
of values get maximized
the
you know special bid i want to propose
here is that they should be on the house
that the optimum assigns to them half
day value
and if i do the same analysis which i
won't go through it it's
somehow the same same
uh inequality applies and i'll just tell
you the one sentence
that it applies because the analysis i
actually did show you in a single item
somehow we'll apply item by item
uh
this person
who you know if a person assigned to
assigned to a has chain the optimum will
have utility at least
half
um
his value for this house minus the price
that someone else paid on that house
and summing that over all players i get
exactly the same band the same analysis
and in fact the same improvement in the
e minus one over e instead of the factor
of a factor of two
the difficulty i want to point out here
is that
in the previous version
the players are capable of beating half
day value here
uh in order to beat half
the value on your optimum assign has a
kind of you have to need to know which
one that might be
and in a
bayesian version or in a learning
version with very various opponents it
might not be always the same house
but turns out the the extension theorem
is more powerful and this is
originally from a pair of papers by
tim rothgarden and vasily
and then the current version is rp per
year later
that it
extension theorem even applies if values
are drawn from independent distributions
despite the difficulty
and extends to learning outcomes
also
it's a nice message it says that we want
to think about learning outcomes even in
a bayesian setting that even everything
is uncertain and changing
all you have to do is this sort of proof
for the full information version and it
automatically extends which i think is
very nice i will not go through the
proof actually more dominantly
because
again this is not a price of energy
tutorial but learning in games tutorial
but the message is still nice and i
guess i want to point out
uh
the difficulty without maybe pointing at
the solution
um
what i want to say is that they should
not be regretting
bidding what the optimum would make them
bid but there is no way for them to
that's not consistent and there's no way
for them to know what that might be
uh instead i want to
consider some slightly
unusual or crazy thing of sampling the
opponent and bidding
as if you guessed what the opponents are
that is you're reading according to the
right distribution what the optimum
would give you but not necessarily
correlated with what people are doing
and it turns out
this works out
what i want to point out about it is
actually one of the things i started in
the beginning
is the difficulty in life
that is
uh this is an application where there
are too many bits to
consider so
optimal bidding
is uh
difficult and learning it is also
difficult or maybe not doable
so i guess this is coming from
a paper of vasily and costas and i guess
they
pointing out that in this application uh
bidding is truly problematic like let's
just think about where we stand there
are very many possible bits to consider
in particular you can build
all on the items or just one item your
choice for every item you bid on you can
build multiple values
it turns out bidding on one item is not
that good an idea you might lose it
maybe rationally you want a bit high on
one item and low on others i'm not so
sure what you should do
uh you can make some elegant
simplifications
um
don't bid above your value that seems
like a dumb idea in the first price
auction uh you can discretize things and
say you want it to stop excellence only
and you don't lose so much um
but even with that finding the optimal
bid or even approximating the optimal
bid is uh is tired and it's a natural
pretty simple reduction from set cover
where
the example is just like what i
suggested you just want to be in one
house
in their example you don't even care
about which has all of them have the
same value for you but turns out
the other bits on the houses are very
high so
you actually my run of it on multiple
houses is to get to make sure you're
winning at least one
and that's where the set cover is you
should
build enough houses but not too many so
that
uh
you win a house but hopefully not too
many because everything you want you
have to pay for
so this meant there's a sort of hint of
why said cover might be relevant here
that's um i guess
uh deciding what is your best bid
even if you know the distribution even
if or you have the past distribution is
a computationally hard problem so
um
it might not be
doable
strategy um
so
i want to give you a little bit of uh
outline of what are the things i'm
hoping to at least at least touch on in
the
in the whatever half an hour i have or
maybe 40 minutes
uh and i think all of these or most of
these are uh nice open directions or
enough open directions that would be
nice to make some progress during the
semester
so what i started with is
pointing out in the previous
slide that bidding might be a finding
the optimal bid even if you know the
distribution of what the opponents are
doing uh is computationally hard
so
you can think about okay what might be
possible when that is true
um
i guess it nice to think about what
happens if for some reason the game
players or the opponents aren't stable
and people playing for only
partial times
and one issue that i have been recently
more thinking about
is what happens in games where
uh it's not a clean new copy of the game
every iteration but there is a sort of
clear carryover effect i guess
uh
one dominant example of this thing is
uh
advertisement auction where the
carryover effect is named your budget
namely if you win the auction you have
uh less money left than if you lose the
action so that's a
pretty clear effect between iterations
um
at the moment i guess i
won't be able to tell you anything very
good about
those points of actions but i can tell
you a little bit about what i do know
and i guess one sort of more dominantly
opens open area
is and i'll come back to this in a
some number of slides if
uh
then cooperation is constructive then no
regret looks like a
exceptionally dumb thing to do and what
might be the better thing to do is a
good question or better ways to analyze
things
so let's just actually uh start with
the example that i started with
is that when it's hard to bid what uh
costas and and vasily are suggesting
that
they can change the benchmark and rather
than thinking about your exact bid
maybe you should think about what subset
of items you're asking for
and
uh maybe
an easier thing to achieve no regret for
is
this condition that's written here and
guess in english what it's trying to do
is instead of averaging
against what's the optimal bid
in which you you know win the item when
it's cheap and not win the item when
it's expensive
just look at the average price of the
item and try to compare compete with
that one that is assuming that you have
to win you have to pay the not the
actual current price but the average
price of the item
uh over time
that's your benchmark what set of items
would you want to want to buy if
you have to pay the average price and
turns out this notion is easier and one
can compete compete for this one and in
fact
uh
what they do is show that uh both that
uh
um
that
uh variant of follow the perturb leader
does achieve does do okay with this what
you need as a subroutine is asking every
iteration given the history of prices
on this ever on the average price so far
what would you want to buy which is a
much more doable task in many
applications
um and turns out this form of no regret
is enough
to guarantee social welfare with a sort
of similar proof than what we have seen
before though i'm not going to
to
elaborate on too much
um
the other place where
there are enough positive results is
learning in in games with changing
population or when there's churn in the
population the
uh model that uh
and vasily and i have been using
is
uh
players
come and go in the players and maybe
gets replaced each every player in each
iteration gets replaced with some
probability uh i wanna keem
uh have the
time that people stay in the game long
enough to allow them to learn
um
and i guess the first thing i should ask
you is
uh what should i expect them to learn
like
the history
i claim that we're going to need a
little bit stronger notion of learning
here
and i guess maybe that's
almost only the only thing i'm going to
show you about this
if this red player here is around for a
period of time it's easily possible
especially if this is a long enough
period that the churn works out so that
um you know when he starts
a certain strategy is really good for
him
but
after a while this guy saw vanish and
some other guys come who make his his
back his routing pass very crowded and
he would be better off switching to a
different one
so a natural form of learning
uh that would be nice
or then actually let's start with an
ideal form of learning what i really
want him to be able to do is is this
choose his strategies
so that
he compares favorably to the
instantaneous optimum every instant of
the time that is as the population
changes the optimum
which i guess i'm thinking of this
alternate strategy ai star t that is the
optimum at time t
this is what i wanted to compare him to
um
but maybe you won't find it too
surprising that was changing population
the optimum is changing and this is
going to be way too sensitive and i
guess just as a simple example as a as a
tester
if you have a matching problem and
they're all these players and the
optimum matching is something
and then only one player vanishes and
the optimal matching changes for
everyone in the game because you know
matching is a sensitive object this is
true for most optimization problems that
the true optimum is easily very
sensitive and so the benchmark that i
hoped for
uh of comparing to the
uh the every time t for the
instantaneous optimum it doesn't appear
to be learnable like that's just too
hard to learn
but there is something that
is close enough and it is actually
learnable and that would be this one
which is
um
adaptive learning that there's a version
where if i compare what utility this
person gets or what cost this person
gets
compared to um
a sequence of changes not necessarily
the optimum but something like that
but i know that the sequence only
changes rarely in particular the model
we're using here is changing it like k
times
that will push up the error parameter
with a factor of k
but
uh is still
as long as k is not very big that is the
change in the
solution that you try to learn is not
very frequent you can do this and one
nice message at least for me personally
is that
the way to achieve this
is to make is to make your your learning
recently biased that is rather than
comparing always to the top history you
should
more heavily favor the more recent part
of your history
which is nice because humans actually
learn that way so that's one of the
outcomes of the human subject
experiments on whether people do
satisfy the nordic-led property all on
their own
suggest that well almost except people
tend to be recently biased so this
suggests that at least in a changing
environment which honestly our life is a
changing environment recency bias is
actually reasonable and that's what
reaches uh high social welfare and at
the super high level without proofs what
we're proving is
that for games that satisfy the
smoothness property
if we can find
a sequence of approximately optimal
solutions
that don't change very often
then
adaptive learners will get close to the
price of energy and again not too
surprisingly but then what we're doing
is
uh assuming that they learning to not
regret this
alternate strategy not very changing
alternate strategy and then compare to
the
welfare that this close to optimal
alternate strategy achieves to be very
concrete
uh i guess our error bands have three
parameters the classical price of energy
band there is a bit of a loss due to
regret error as we always had and there
is this last item which i guess we call
beta is the loss because our stable
solution is only approximately optimal
and not exactly optimal
um so what i did so far and this is
going to be a stopping point and i'm
going to
maybe switch gears to something that i
view as a
is more open
uh is tell you about results that are
very smoothness smoothness framework
heavy that is i showed you some variant
of the smoothness framework was the
original one and this action variant
and then
i view two sets of results or two
results that are extending it to other
kind of games so i guess
i view the uh
the bus costas and vasily is that on
multi-dimensional auctions
also like that it's using a very similar
uh argument to smoothness and what they
do is not exactly no regret learning but
still it's uh
a variant of follow the per term leader
so it's similar and that what we're
doing here with costas and and todoris
is definitely that is an extension of
um
of
of using heavily using the smoothness
framework
one important assumption
that
uh i
you know like to spend my remaining half
an hour on is
sometimes this whole no regret or the
smoothness framework is not applicable
and one place this is when
uh there is some carryover effect or
some other sign of direct effect
in between the games uh beyond the fact
that of course everyone
is uh is learning from the past data
there's some other effect happening here
uh
one painful place where this happens is
cooperative games and i will only spend
maybe
two slides or one on cooperative games
because i don't have anything very
intelligent to offer uh but
it's a painful place where
no regret seems very much the wrong
definition
and just to drive the example they they
point on um
think of two-person game repeated
prisoner dilemma i guess desire
utilities so uh if
a person cop
if uh if they both defect two players
the fact they both get
and
uh
that is half the police then they both
get 10-year prison terms
if uh
one of them defects and have the police
the other one uh doesn't then
the person who who
defected gets a small reward and other
one gets an even bigger prison sentence
and of course if both of them continue
to cooperate then
the police can't can't penalize them
obviously the only good thing to do is
to for both of them to cooperate at
least
ideally uh in the repeated game but the
only nash equilibrium is game is to uh
defect the fact
and in fact uh that's the only no regret
strategy is to defect all the time
if you do anything else then the fact
uh
that's not
that's that you have regret and that's
because uh
what this regret notion suggested
is you're not taking into account that
if you change your strategy the opponent
might change the the strategy uh it has
a
your your strategy or your actions have
an effect
beyond your payoff it's inducing the
other guy to do something and that's not
being taken into effect that as you will
change your strategy then your opponent
will also change your strategy that is
hoping that
if you always defect you can only affect
the expect the opponent to defect also
uh if you cooperate maybe he will
cooperate also um
there are suggested learning algorithms
of what might be better here
the more recent aurora decal tewari
paper cost and policy regret which is a
nice name that is the you regret for
trying a
particular kind of algorithm
and they have some
results on things that maybe you can
prove certainly it's a regret that's
achievable it's a doable thing it is a
very reasonable algorithmically simple
but may maybe making a decent behavior
assumption
would be nice to be able to prove that
it actually pays off in many classes of
games
what i can tell you about
is work i've been doing uh
with
my current graduate one of my current
graduate students in in a
package writing or
a ratting style game which also has a
similar carryover effect certainly much
simpler than cooperative games uh and
maybe i spent some minutes to tell you a
little bit about that one
so i guess this is only morning russia
traffic
uh i do not expect anyone to cooperate
with me
uh
or
traffic of some port but i want to point
out that there is a carryover effect
here too maybe not in the morning russia
because no matter how bad monday morning
traffic is by tuesday morning
before tuesday morning everyone went
home uh or wherever they went
but if i think of the smaller time scale
either cars or packets in the second by
second then
any car or packet that caused congestion
and minute number second number whatever
as a millisecond later they're still
there causing the very same congestion
so there's a carryover effect or in case
of package wrapping when the congestion
is big this packets get dropped and then
they're going to get get resend it's
still a carryover effect the package
didn't make it to the destination and
they need descending
um
so i guess the question that we were
trying to ask is
what can we say about price of energy
balance in games when there is
dependence between the rounds
um in the
particular game i can ask the question
of the style of the packet of the
traffic wrapping with early traffic
writing paper via the steam how much
extra capacity
guarantees good good performance but the
question i want to emphasize for this
talk is the second one
what does learning mean here and there's
no regret learning the sort of right
form of learning
and here
the carryover effect is simpler than
whether or not your opponent cooperates
so
i'm sort of hoping one can maybe answer
this question
uh
it's an easier thing to answer and hope
more hopefully to immediately make
progress on it
so
let me tell you a little bit of the
model that you're using again
i will not do a lot of sort of detailed
match but i do want to show you both the
results and the
the the uh
issue with learning so i have to show
you what the model is so our model is a
very simple queuing model their cues
this packet
uh every q
has some packets arriving at some lathe
like maybe
for qi the burnley process with weight
londi
servers are capable of serving packets
uh maybe they have a rate too but if you
don't like that then they could be
perfect that like they can be perfect at
serving packets
won't affect the results or
and
um the assumption is that each time each
queue can send one packet to one of the
servers
the servers can
process one packet at a time and i'm
going to assume for simplicity
that they return all the answers packets
that is drop them and they can have to
get recent
uh and
uh i guess the tie breaking as to you
know
if there are multiple packets which one
do they serve we're going to assume that
they
they try to their packets are time
stamps and they're making an attempt to
try to serve the oldest of the packets
this is really helpful
because it helps the auth packets clear
which is will turn out to be really
necessary if i want to have any hope of
any positive results
so again the question we're asking how
much extra capacity do i need uh to
serve every packet
uh i spent maybe two seconds to sort of
or two sides to help you a little bit
like get what the model does so if i go
down to one q one once one q one server
then that's a very classical 101 queuing
theory model
lambda arrival rate new service rate um
if lambda is less than you then you're
okay
and the
expected queue size will remain banded
uh you can think of it as a biased voc
on the half line bias towards uh zero
if q if if turns out lambda equals mu
then the qs will grow maybe not at a
linear rate but still grow and if lambda
is greater than you that's very clear uh
there's more packets arriving than you
can serve and there will be an infinite
line
of package unsearched packets
uh
and that's you know this is sharp and
simple
uh
the model was originally suggested by a
nip 16 paper by krishna sami sanjohari
and sakotai uh who actually had queue
and multiple servers and it's a
version of multi-arm bandit problem
where they wanted a finer analysis not
only that this uh
queue will learn which one is the good
server to send the packets to but rather
uh how long the queue behind him before
he figures out where to send it so
obviously the necessary condition is
that one of the servers is good enough
to take his his uh arriving packets
remember he can only send to one place
at the time
uh but they did a finer analysis
understanding how long will it take to
to get this served our version there are
multiple queues and multiple servers
to answer the question of how much extra
capacity needs i guess we had to start
with sort of a baseline measure suppose
i were to coordinate how much do i need
and that's not very hard to establish i
guess because this is a baseline
optimization measure i just assume that
everything is ordered that that queues
and servers come in
in in you know order by the arrival rate
and capacity and the condition is
that
you know that the highest arrival rate q
must have a server that can take its
packet so this is the condition here
with k equals one that is the highest
lambda is less less than the highest
view
that also the two top top arriving
queues uh have tall arrival rate less
than the two top servers that is the two
top launders are less than the two top
news
in in some again
two uh queues can only be sent to two
two servers so we need that condition
this condition is obviously necessary
for every k
and it turns out it's
uh
sort of matching style argument not very
hard to prove that it's actually
sufficient
but our main theorem says
that if all cues use no regret learning
to figure out what to do
then
twice as much is enough
and this turns out to be sharp so again
the necessary condition for coordinated
situation is that top kqs have arrival
rate less than the sum of the service
rates of top care servers
turns out if they only doing it we are
learning algorithm then the necessary
condition is that top k
uh
cues the arrival rate is less than half
the service rate of the top case servers
at this late point in life i certainly
don't want to go through a whole
detailed proof but maybe verse 2
at least flips through quickly slides do
i i and i will pause the slides that
have the outline the proof is a
potential function argument
uh the potential we are using or at
least the intuition for the potential
we're using came from
uh
some of
uh
many potentials phyta is the number of
packaged packets in the system that are
age or older and i send this over all
the packets so
old packets contributes a lot to this
potential function the younger packets
contribute less
obviously this potential function is is
is good in the sense that if i keep this
potential low
then there can't be old packets there
because a very old packet contributes
itself a ton to this potential function
the main tool we use is a as a nice
probabilistic probability theorem by p
mental and rosenthal that if i have any
random process of is a function phi
uh which
when phi is high has negative is regular
which we're going to sleep under the rug
but when phi is high it has negative
gift that is it tends to decrease or
decreases an expectation then
uh it remains banned in expectation
overall times
uh and i guess the main thing we have to
prove that the no regret assumption and
the factor of two slack will imply the
negative drifts
uh then this function is high
so
you know maybe a sentence of why
why
no regret helps
i guess i really prefer to think of this
particular time towel and the packets
that are toweled or older
that's a nice group because overall as a
group they have priority over everything
else so this is a group of things that
has priority
i fix a long window and
the best servers and i can think of a
option a
they sent to those servers and remember
the condition is that they have planning
capacity
actually twice as much which i don't
even need for this part of the argument
and they send it to that you know even
half the time then we're okay we have
enough cleared
that the expectation should the
potential function should decrease
of course we don't know they are
standing there but that's where no
regrets will kick in if they're not
standing there
then
they must be not regretting that they
didn't send there
and if they're not sending there then
these queues the best the servers the
best service servers are spending empty
half the time and they will have
priority they could have gotten a lot of
service out of them
by no regret they must be getting at
least as much service someplace
else um
and again i take it to all these time
scales and add them up and that's why we
get the band
uh to be honest i admit that there are
some slight details here the technical
extra detail is that
uh in first of all uh this is an
infinite process so one has to be a
little careful with expectation even low
probability events are always going to
happen and uh second
uh the condition technical condition on
the premental rosenthal result requires
that
that uh
that the process has bonded moments
which the way i described it does not so
we have to switch the probabilistic
description
but this is not what i wanted to
emphasize
the
parts that i wanted to actually get
across and spend some time on
is this last uh thought that i was
hoping to uh have you guys all
appreciate
is an interesting example
for this process so remember
going back
a page the process was
that
sir the skews have packets arriving i
guess in this case there's uh two queues
both have packets arriving a bit higher
late than half
so if like you know half of the time
they get a packet roughly speaking at
random
and we have two servers here
one is a perfect server if anyone sends
a packet he can send one you can serve
one the other one is less than half rate
it's not a very good server
so what do we know about this
uh first of all i want to start by
saying that
there is plenty capacity here the
centralized scheduling rules it does
satisfy easily like remember the rule
was that the arrival rate for the
highest arrival package should be less
than the
service rate of the best server yeah
point 51 is less than one all set
and second that the
top two uh arrival rates which combined
to 1.2 here should be less than the top
two servers again their home one point
roughly speaking one against 1.5 yes
surely
uh it does not satisfy the factor of too
bad
uh actually on either account but most
dominantly because the two two top
numbers sum to
above one and this is only one and a
half so it's missing it by quite imagine
and indeed knowing that learners are not
going to succeed um i claim that what
knowing that learners do is both of them
sent to the top servers
now why do they do that
well at this point they should get a
service rate
of a half right i mean they're about
symmetric
sometimes one is older sometimes the
other one but roughly speaking they're
splitting the rates so getting across at
50 50.
and i made the arrival rate just a
little bit above so
uh
that's not good enough but that's what
they're going to get 50 percent
um but more noticeably
the other server is worse
so they're getting 50 on top that's
better than 0.47 so clearly we're home
50 is optimal
but yet
of course the getting winner grows
because 50 is not good enough they
slowly slowly
increasing
and growth
okay so far nothing interesting happened
it's an example where our theorem
doesn't apply because there is not a
factor of two and indeed learning is not
good enough
but here is the painful fact if one of
them would change to this by which i
mean a randomized strategy in which he
sends ten percent of the time to the
bottom server and ninety percent of time
to the top server or some other percent
like that
what do you think would happen
so i claim that
in a more smarter learner this is a
selfish move
um
that i claim that it selfishly helps
now a priory you might say that no no no
it's a it's a you know it's a nice move
towards the top guy
because you know ninety percent of the
time he competes but ten percent of the
time he doesn't so he's really helping
the top guy who
you know
splits the traffic ninety percent of the
time but ten percent it's all his so he
has an advantage
uh which is very true it definitely
helps the top guy
but it turns out
actually helps the bottom guy also they
both clear
um
and it's not very
not very hard to see why
uh true
he's helping his neighbor more than he's
helping himself but he's happy enough to
both of them
uh because of what he's doing down here
uh when he goes up he's quite often the
older packet
and therefore he actually going to be
way more than half the time when he
competes
which is happening because some of the
time he's using the lesser server and
this way actually both of them clear
but notice
he actually has regret he has even more
regret than what we had before i made
him switch to this user because now his
sir his success rate on top is better
than a half
and yet
this is actually good for him
so
somehow
regret
appears to be the wrong notion
um
and in fact it does actually help even
in the actual theorems so but i gave you
a little hint of having proof that if
everyone is a no regret learner we need
a factor of two
uh
buffer in the in the capacities
if i instead assume that they they
somehow have this patient or better
evaluation of what's going on and choose
optimal strategies that way then i don't
need a factor of 2 i need a bit less
than that e over n minus 1
which is a sharper band
but
instead of telling you you know why the
second theorem is true i just want to
emphasize of what exactly happened here
so what i'm claiming is that these cues
uh nor regret learning was too myopic
and this is something that you know such
a learning heavy community i'm sure you
guys all appreciate but maybe it's worse
still writing at the improved notation
in this game because of the carryover
effect what happens in iteration t
doesn't only depend on what you did in
iteration t it depends on the whole damn
history
like of who had a packet and who could
send and how it was your packet all
depending on what happened in the past
so a better notation would be
is your cost or maybe utility
uh
at your player i
at iteration t given the whole history
up to t and i want to sum this over time
t
and what no regret does is compares it
to this animal here on the other side
which is the cost
if everything stayed the same but on
iteration t you tried something else
this is what no regret proves about this
is what no regret considers and it is
not regret proofs to prove to you that
that's what it's considering it's best
to actually think of what are norgat
algorithms doing
they're playing
explore exploit strategy that is every
now and then they're randomly trying to
do something and then evaluating how
well it works and then repeating this
thing that worked well in the past
this is explore doing this switching to
something for a second and then backing
off let's explore
and that's what they're doing and that's
the benchmark that they're competing
against and maybe what we really meant
is this
that is what would have happened had i
consistently use this x strategy
um
that's what we really meant or maybe i
don't mean
from all the way from the beginning but
at least for a while to see the
long-term effect of this strategy and
not just the instantaneous effect and
again paging back to the example that i
find very insightful the instantaneous
effect of using this is very painful
because this is a low rate and remember
what is getting there is even better
than half but the long term effect is
good and i guess a more patient learner
would somehow take into account
the
long-term effect
um
so you know the band we prove is
actually uh not a learning band so maybe
less relevant um we
proved something about the stationary
equilibrium of
uh
of of this game as a i guess a
equilibrium analysis
um
for that particular thing this e minus c
over e minus one
band is actually sharp but maybe that's
not
uh the main message for this talk
uh
instead i should sort of try to
tell you a little bit of what are the
things that i would like to think about
using this special semester
um i guess before that of course i love
learning
um
it's a good way to enter a game no need
for come on prior uh but here's a
sentence i said a lot
uh
takes advantage of the opponent playing
badly that i never could make a sense
out of in a sort of more
sort of a theory framework that would
explain it makes sense in english but
would be nice to actually prove
something like this
of one way is it
actually of a like if you play in a
zero-sum game you play the nash
aquilibrium then you guaranteed to get
the next outcome no matter what the hell
the opponent does
uh
if the opponent is bad you should be
able to do better and learning asic does
that but i guess it's not in a way that
i know how to argue about it
um i guess i try to show you that
learning sometimes does well and
um
even okay to have some carryover effect
though there are many many carryover
effect games where we don't know how to
do similar analysis and i guess the sort
of killer application or dominant
application is is actions with budgets
there are some nice papers that try to
think about what does learning mean in a
budgeted scenario but i think there are
lots of
uh
things i wish i knew better and i don't
and then uh i guess the last question i
got to
is you know uh can the other forms of
learning that can do better
uh i'm hoping policy regret of aurora
decal tewari might be an interesting
target here or just actually a more
patient regret that is instead of trying
everything once you
you know check on the longer term
long-term effect which is roughly
speaking what the police the
no policy regret algorithm of uh aurora
deca and tavares doing also is trying
strategies for one step for two step or
four step
and sort of see how it works uh
unfortunately this is a conjecture i
ended the talks
about this problem
in earlier rounds but very recently uh
this
uh
new paper
pointed out that
no policy that as a behavioral
assumption is not strong enough to get
our improvement from the factor of two
in the particular queuing application so
uh
it does seem like the example is very
artificial so maybe there is a slightly
better assumption than one can go around
but
that conjecture is not as good as it
used to be
so thanks so much for
paying attention and i guess
uh tolerating my online version and i
love to
uh answer some questions if
um people have questions
very much evan
do you have any questions
[Music]
so thank you so much for the great
tutorial so i have one question about
the first price auction
so you mentioned that that game is a
smooth it's a half a smooth but then in
that game you only have the bidders and
then
uh
and there is no auctioneer who who is
also optimizing its prices so i'm just
wondering if the notion of smoothness
can be extended if um
you also include the the platform
reduction here into the system so i'm
having like bunch of uh leaders and also
that they're optimizing their reading
strategy and there's a platform
reduction here which optimizes is within
a strategy do i still have a smooth game
um
i guess
not
i guess we have to discuss about the
what the framework
actually is
uh
but i guess
i i'm certainly not aware of results
that claim this the simplest version
would be to say that what the actioner
can do is set a reserve price
so he's committed to running first price
auction
um but he can announce that or or maybe
not announce but like as a his strategy
is to set a price himself and say
i won't sell it unless it's at least
such and such uh you know we know from
the classical myerson thing that uh you
know regular one shot actions that
setting reserved fire is a good idea
uh it pushes the
bidders to bit higher um
even
even though of course if if uh you don't
sell the item then there is no social
value but it does increase the revenue
of the auctioneer so it's a selfish move
for them
uh
and that's a good point if if the price
of energy results would work with
reserve price setting auctioneer
uh
the
sort of broader question
which i think
is uh interesting but less well or less
clearly mathematically phrasable or at
least i don't know how to phrase it well
if the auctioneer is deciding the format
of the action so exactly what should be
the rules of the action just because
that's more open and it's not clear what
the strategies are in that game i mean
for the actioner
but i there might be million people in
the audience who might know the answer
better than to this than better than i
do feel free to speak up and
offer a better
you know reference or a better uh
pointer
um any more questions from the audience
one question i had about the last
stateful
framework is that it was still in the
fully adversarial scenario is there
anything in between where maybe you know
there's some stochastic pattern of how
the system reacts
or maybe have offline data of how the
system reacts in the long term and that
could be useful
some
blend between adversarial and plastic
that would help
this is for the qa queueing question
yeah for the question or more generally
when you have uh when your actions have
long-term
lasting
impact
i mean there is something stolastic in
the way we setting up the q in question
because the arrival rates are still a
stick so
there is some
stylistic uncertainty that we're
actually already taking using
to our advantage
um
i i guess it's a nice like generally you
know stars statisticity should help
um
uh i guess a nice question and i'm not i
don't have a clear answer right now
sorry
[Music]
uh hi everyone discusses um a very
interesting talk first of all uh and i
also really enjoyed the last part about
the carryover effect i was i was curious
uh what is the so you presented a
specific application where clearly there
was impact to the state
of people's choices
uh what is the what would be a broader
framework for us to think about uh
carryover effects like uh
um
like
do you think of it as a broader question
i mean of course you think of it as a
broadcast but do you have a framework
for us to think about where you know
stays affected by actions and you know
in some way and
how should we think about it more
generally
that's a cool question actually i was i
don't know it's a nice suggestion i
haven't
i did think about like the other sort of
killer application is such an effective
budget
uh and that's a you know
budget has this like i guess a different
effect on the game is this corporation
which i know
uh
many people thought about certainly
the
you know i i talked to many people about
it i guess uh aurora is definitely
someone i i spent time talking about
this
uh
it's it's hard because somehow you have
to know
you know will the opponent react
and
it just somehow seems i don't know at
some point i was more hopeful that one
can get
uh
get results of
games like
like uh you know cost sharing games
where where
one would hope the moment like if i
if i start doing something maybe the
opponent will try to share with me and
that
will benefit both of us
uh
i thought this kind of games was the
budgeted version and this package rat
thing
has the nice property
that
uh the carryover effect
is
not really dependent on other people
reacting to you
yes they can react to you that's always
a lab but in this example when you
start using the lesser server it's
indirectly helping you
uh or it's helping you
even if the other guy doesn't react it
does nothing it still helps you
and the budget is that way too the the
carryover effect is not about other
people's reaction it's directly on your
space you have more money you have less
money
so i was more thinking of other examples
where
where
this might apply and i guess if i think
of
my personal agenda here is trying to
prove similar results on other examples
and that made me frame them as a
framework but maybe you're right that i
should
take the framework question more
immediately up front
interesting
thank you very much eva
and thanks everyone for attending and
now there's going to be a a reception
for the next hour and thanks eva again
for the wonderful club thank you all for
listening and
enjoy your reception i hope in some in a
month or so i will actually come for one
of the workshops and get to talk to all
of you
bye everyone